my name is tiana marie my name is
daenerys
my name is dominique and i'm one of the
producers at great big story
we understand the importance of
amplifying black voices so we reached
out to people from all over the country
to hear what they had to say this is
what they wish you now
i wish you knew
i wish people knew just how much i love
being black
my name is tyler gibson and i'm a son a
brother
and a husband
for as many positive experiences i have
i think i have just as many if not more
negative experiences where someone tried
to take that joy of being black away
from me
over time all those negative experiences
build up i've just become numb to it
my name is alexa chanel ashio and i'm a
special education teacher
i want people to understand that black
is a big word it shouldn't be confined
to one culture or
one type of people if you are filled
with melanin
you are black that's an okay thing to be
it's okay to be black call me
what i am
my name is archie page and i am a queer
storyteller
it's like you're having a regular day
and then a senseless murder
like trayvon martin's happens and you
think that could easily have been me
you think it's gonna be dark outside
soon should i even bother wearing
a hoodie or will i risk getting shot
in spite of all of that for me being
black is a gift
i want people to know that to be black
in america
is to know i've inherited a legacy of
courage and resilience
my name is rashira dobson and i am a
philanthropist
who is disabled
there are 53 million disabled americans
and out of those 53 million
5.6 are disabled black americans
how obvious to be a minority within a
minority group
it's almost like you feel invisible
twice
my name is daenerys fraser and i teach
black and brown students
i wish you knew that
there is a stark difference
between empathy and sympathy
no one needs your pity no one needs your
your sorrow we have enough of that
something about
melanin something about blackness evokes
this like visceral fear
that's one side that's leading to the
senseless killings
and murder of those people this fear
something that does not exist in reality
it is a figment of our imagination
that leads to people actually dying
just crazy i hope that people can muster
up
enough courage to never give up on
leading people out of ignorance
my name is bria randall and i work in
human resources
i was 13 years old at my first
big slumber party the girls and i were
sitting around popcorn watching a movie
and as i reached to get some more
popcorn a girl
across from me said your hands make you
look like a gorilla
and i'd never heard anything like that
before i think what hurt worse than her
saying that hateful comment was the fact
that not one person
stood up for me my name is chelsea and
i'm a medical student
it shouldn't take murder for you to
advocate for your fellow human
if this is the first time that you're
actually giving a damn and taking action
in regards to black
issues then i want you to understand and
respect
that that is where you are in your
evolution
my name is ramona lindsey and i've been
a nurse for 50 years
this country that i love so dearly is
still
mired in undeserved and useless
prejudices
now is the time to share these
experiences
in hopes you see the past and the
similarities to now
that is the only way to help change the
future
[Music]
my name is charmaine shoeford
and i am an english and history teacher
[Music]
i wish you knew how much it hurts
to see fellow black people suffer at the
hands of people who
don't take the time to understand them
and you meet one black person
you've literally only met one black
person
my name is josina campbell and i am a
multifaceted creative
[Music]
we get killed we get nailed on spit on
dirt thrown on our name falsely accused
you name it
and somehow we still pull up and show
out as a culture
every single time we keep going
reminded that we are kings and queens
first
so don't let up say it at the top of
your lungs apply
pressure let it be known you deserve to
be in the room
every single room
i wish you knew that we are human too
we hold these tools to be self-evident
that all men are created
[Applause]
thank you so much for watching we got
tons of submissions and unfortunately we
could not include them all
but we did add them to our site so if
you'd like to hear the full versions of
the stories you just heard
plus many more click the link below